hey guys i'm ryan right and i'm katie du
bois for back support Katie and I are
gonna try to just talk to you guys look
directly in the camera I know you love
it when youtubers do that even while
we're in conversation trying to just
look at you real conversation we're
having right now we're gonna check out a
very Murray Christmas Netflix trailer
whatever I'm gonna look at you if I need
to I merely slouch when I look at me I
feel like I have to slouch I feel it it
feels maybe like I feel better - very
Merry Christmas Bill Murray trailer for
a Netflix special all right let's do
this
she likes Bill Murray a lot I'm not
really up to date with Bill Murray's
latest I did watch like the classics Oh
crab legs and those Buster's and with
stripes I don't know yeah the one
reading listen the army never saw that
he'll Rainey's directed it Green was the
director Groundhog Day and Ghostbusters
- have you seen quick change ah I was
one of his funniest oh it seems like I
have to catch up with all of that yeah
man Garfield Garfield to a tale of two
kitties I know that's work he's ever
done
I can't do this I'm sorry what are you
doing come on let's do the show
the airports are closed the trains are
closed the buses and bridges and tunnels
are not working the entire city of New
York is shut down
is it cloning the clinic loonies Georgia
Sophia Coppola boos we've got attractive
people
all right she's nice I'm gonna sing A
Christmas Carol and I need a volunteer
and that person is gonna be you right
over here blowing up birds stay off
grease and my my okay you're not a
singer and we don't have time to find
out if your dancer the greatest night
it's like so [ __ ] that Clooney in the
background for a Christmas special turn
her off
you were like a Christmas isn't what a
mess we have George cool I rest my case
he saw monuments men how was it you were
so good you were great
I'm sold
whoa I'm like super so I did not see
that coming that's whoa I was like okay
Bill Murray's in this cool yes we be on
the all-star cast what I'm really
excited for is the fact that Sophia
Coppola is directing this I mean she did
lost in translation and that's what
really broke out Bill Murray into like
dramatic roles and she that was I think
that's his best dramatic performance
I've seen granted there's films I got to
catch up on but that was that's still
been my favorite thus far so seeing
Sophia Coppola come back she hasn't
really done anything that I was like
mesmerized by after lost in translation
but she clearly gets Bill Murray
yeah and in there a cop it's a comedy
this time around but it feels like
there's gonna be some drama a little bit
of news I love the industry secrets
thing you know it's like all of the
things that the people within the
industry like really are thinking and
the rest of the world doesn't have to
yeah exactly but just like they're
called I'm like yeah because they're not
just normal people
those girls are around celebrities all
the time absolutely yeah good point
obviously excited for George Clooney and
like these seem like people that like
Bill Murray a lot you know cuz Bill
Murray I've heard is like the most
selective person when it comes to what
work he takes on yeah I heard it's a
[ __ ] I read a whole article about it
was one of the movies he started in late
recently and this director was talking
about how it was the most like grueling
process just to get in touch with Bill
Murray it doesn't have like a manager an
agent you gotta find a way to get
through to his lawyer who hopefully will
be able to get Bill Murray to so it's
like the fact that Bill Murray agree to
something so big this is Netflix sure
son of a movie theater experience but
there's a whole [ __ ] cast and it's
led by Bill Murray it's cool to see Bill
Murray back in something that's like
looks like a true Christmas delight
especially if you're into movies I was
thinking the same thing about George
Clooney we've seen from the past I don't
know 10 years almost all dramatic
performances yeah and now we get him
back in comedy well it's Marie and
Clooney
cuz I know he does comedy sometimes like
with the Cohen bro
like he did intolerable cruelty and oh
brother were heart now and burn after
reading so he does a comedy every once
in a while I would like to see George
Clooney play like a mock version of
himself George Clooney playing a
character is George Clooney you know
like that sounds fun and I love Amy
Poehler
I mean she's one of my favorites I mean
Rashida [ __ ] god this is just such a
great great group
yeah and it's a Christmas movie and I
feel like we don't get really good
Christmas movies that much anymore
and I want to see a really good one and
I feel like if Bill Murray's this
involved in Sofia Coppola and all these
cast members all these guys got on board
it's gotta be something rewarding you
know I hope so too hope they did for
more than just money know that strike me
as people who do this stuff just for
money maybe they just don't really like
each other anyway guys thanks for tuning
in to the channel if you're new to the
channel click this button above me to
subscribe and become a rejected a Katie
du Bois has a Facebook Instagram Twitter
she guest-starred in a web series that
just launched on YouTube called me you
him and she's in three of the episodes
it's a funny show in it stars three
black guys which is cool it's really
cool yeah right that's the way to not
sound that you're you're getting there
I'm Lucia
Enrique Coronado what's up Ryan I've
been a fan of your work for several
months now and I think you're an awesome
guy he did a possessive way not you are
' and I hope I'm not forcing about this
but since I'm majoring in film was
wondering if you'd like to watch one of
my three short films for my youtube
channel let me know what you think and
keep up the good work PS I would love to
be on your show tell Veronica I said hi
well the key to come in on the real
rejects is you got to be as good-looking
as me unfortunately I haven't been able
to find a girl or a guy who looks as
good as me you get beautiful intelligent
women on the show and said let's go back
to Enrique for a second okay Enrique I
gotta say man you're one handsome devil
you're one handsome devil there's a
problem though my girlfriend likes
Hispanic guys a lot yeah I mean that's
her favorite thing I don't know why I'm
assuming that but that's that's her
thing and you look like a really
good-looking Hispanic guy and my
girlfriend's half Mexican you two are
gonna be attracted to each other sure
what I want to threesome with the both
of you maybe who knows chances of that
happening
not likely she's not down for something
like that so she's gonna leave me for
you I don't know if I could have you on
this channel and reget sorry
I'm trying not to jump to conclusions
these days but I can't help her just
remember what we talked about okay
deep breathing that was really good I
was really peaceful